The Joe Rogan experience
and I couldn't agree more.
My hope is that what you were saying and
what we were discussing earlier about
how the Internet has sort of eroded our
faith in many institutions as being the
only or the primary source of knowledge
that I hope that that takes place
globally in terms of the way we view
government. Yeah. And that we do that.
Your idea of like,
I love what America stands for and what
America stands for is kind of a nation.
That's where people go to,
you know,
this is one of the more insidious problems
with this idea of building walls and
keeping people out and making it
incredibly difficult to get here.
The reason why I'm here is because
it was pretty easy to get here. Yeah.
That's why I'm here.
That's not,
that's the essence of America.
A free and open society
come here and do better.
Yes.
That's the whole idea behind it and I
would hope that this idea of being able to
just, if you want to do manner
that you can anywhere in the world,
this could eventually spread
out. Yes. This is my hope.
I believe it can spread out and, and um,
you know, I see many signs of hope, uh,
in, in, in America. America has
become a big part of my life,
not just because I wrote this book,
but because I have children
who are now living in America.
I have a son and daughter in law who,
who live in La.
I have another son and daughter in law
who live in Boston. America. I'm British,
but America has become a very central
part of my life and it's a fascinating and
amazing country and it's been my privilege
to travel thousands of miles across
America, across many, many, many different
states. And I, I love this country. It's,
it's,
it's an amazing place.
Only in America could we see happening.
What has happened with cannabis, you
know, the, the, the fact that at a,
at a local level, individuals have
got together, mobilized petitions,
organized votes, and changed
the law, change the law. Diff,
literally stuck a finger up at
central government and said, fuck off.
This is none of your business.
What I do with my consciousness in the
inner sanctum of my own life is not the
business of the state.
That's a very American feeling.
It's something that you don't find often
in other countries where the state is
granted much more power and much more
authority than it perhaps should be.
Americans are naturally questioning
of government authority and that has,
that is what has led to the legalization
increasing legalization of cannabis,
which is going to change
the world in lots of ways.
But then ironically at the same time,
see the thing about democracies
is that in order to,
um,
get things done in a democracy,
you need to persuade people
of your point of view.
So information becomes very important in,
in democracies and the
information can be abused,
people can be misled with information.
They can be told that what they're
receiving is the truth, whereas in fact,
it's not the truth.
And you can end up with a
kind of dictatorship that
the people have given their
ascent to on the of of false
information. And frankly, I'd rather
have a real dictatorship, which is,
which is out in the open and clear
rather than one that has been subtly
manipulated into position
through manipulating the, the,
the, the views of the, of,
of,
of the voters.
But I am and remain enormously
encouraged by America.
It may seem like a trivial issue,
but the fact that state by state
cannabis is being legalized and that is
resulting from a grassroots movement
that this enormous change has been made
either. It's ironic, it's strange
that at the federal level,
even though what eight states now
totally legal for recreational, uh, 23,
24 states legal for medical use,
that at the federal level,
it's still a schedule one controlled,
controlled drug.
This is a huge state of dissonance that
exists in America is going to have to
put it right. What it says to me
is that people can change things,
people can get together at the local
level and they can make a better world
because there's no doubt that the cannabis
laws were vicious and wrong and cruel
and evil and ruined people's
lives for, for, for decades.
And it's people who've changed that
it's not government has changed,
that it's the people at the grassroots
level in America is a country where that
can happen.
And I,
I remain encouraged about about the role
of the American people while often in
despair about the role of the American
state. Yeah. I'm encouraged as well.
And you know, it's interesting, Ben
and Jerry released something yesterday,
which was really are on
four 20 I should say,
which was talking about the
drug laws in this country. And,
and talking about how many,
it's real really opening this,
the,
the idea of like how unjust these laws
were and how many of these laws targeted
people of color and how many people who
are white people have profited off of
this and how many people
are still in jail. Yes.
For crimes that they committed,
you know,
air quote crimes that are no longer
cry that are no longer crimes. Yeah.
And this is ridiculous. These, these
records should be expunged. They should,
because I see that California has
made some steps in that direction.
There has been some expunging of course.
Well,
we can only hope that also what opens up
next is silicide Ben is now going to be
on the ballot. Absolutely.
And when that opens up,
I mean what you really think
marijuana is a gateway drug.
Well guess what it is if silicide gets in.
Yes.
Cause Psilocybin can legitimately change
the world yet so and can't really,
I mean I think marijuana can change
the world and I really do think that
cannabis is changing people's perceptions
and making people more calm and
friendly and yeah, and even the,
what they talk about with paranoia.
I welcome that.
And the reason why I welcome that as I
think people are entirely too cocky. Yeah.
The, the life we live as bizarre as you
could ever imagine book and we're just
accustomed to it because it's
our day to day for granted. Yeah.
Marijuana removes those blinders and it
really makes you understand that this is
a strange, strange life. And these,
a lot of these pitfalls and problems that
we have in our society are due to fear
and they're due to ignorance and their,
their due to this,
this lack of connection with
each other and cannabis and many
of these other psychedelic drugs,
they encourage this connection with each
other, which is I think what we need.
It's, it's certainly
what we need. And, and,
and it's an aberration in human culture
that we've created a society that
demonized the,
the substances and that made them illegal.
It's a relatively recent
thing. It's really just the
last, the last hundred years.
It's, uh, it's, it's a tiny
part of the human story.
And yet we were so arrogant as a society
that we could set aside thousands of
years of human tradition and experience
and wisdom working with the plant
medicines. We just set it aside, turn
them into criminal substances and say,
we know everything. What a, what a
huge and stupid mistake that is, um,
on cannabis as a quote
unquote gateway drug.
It absolutely is in this sense that the
legalization of cannabis is going to
open the doors to, as, as you say, to
the legalization of, of psychedelics.
Because what's happening is that the
population is completely waking up to the
fact that they have been bullshitted
and lied to about cannabis for the best
part of a century.
And once that dawns on people,
the realization at a direct personal
level, here's this herb I love,
I have been lied to,
systematically misinformed by
central government, uh, about this,
about this herb that leads to questioning
of everything that central government
does. And so in that sense, it is
a gateway to a questioning society.
The psychedelics are different
in that, in that Psilocybin, um,
actually does lead you to question stuff.
It leads you to really ask
questions about, about everything,
about your role in the world,
about you as a person,
about how you relate to other people and
about the whole system on this planet
and the, the beautiful,
gorgeous planet that we,
that we have and what we're doing to
it. That also enters, enters awareness.
So it erodes confidence and authority.
And it also roads,
confidence and authority that doesn't
have experiences that you've experienced.
That's the part of the problem is that
these people that are holding people back
from these psychedelic experiences,
they've never had them. They've never had,
they don't even know
what they're rallying.
That coming to it from a place
of fear and prejudice, uh,
there simply accepting stuff that they'd
been told without really thinking it
through and, and, and examining
it. And again, it's a failure of,
of what human beings should,
should be doing. We have to get,
we have to get rid of this fear.
And ironically it's bad for them as well.
I've taught for the people that
are actually encouraging this,
these laws to be enforced.
Yes. Is it bad for,
it's bad for the whole of the whole of
society because it is healthy for a,
for a society where adults
become self realized,
individuals where they make their own
responsible choices about their own lives,
where they don't say, oh, government
met must make this choice for me.
That's the next step for humanity.
We start,
we need to start becoming our own leaders
and making our own choices and that is
that is what's being revealed now that
we're getting to the skull beneath the
smile of the war on drugs.
We're realizing that it's part of a big
program of lying that has been about
keeping people's minds closed down,
not wanting free thinking.
I've made this point several times,
but our society is not against altered
states of consciousness. As such a,
our society will allow big Pharma to
make billions of dollars with drugs that
alter consciousness like Ciroc,
satin, Prozac, antidepressants,
which in my opinion having had some
experience of them are amongst the most
horrible drugs on the planet. They are
very harmful, very dangerous drugs,
but they're completely legal and they're
encouraged with our system. Likewise,
alcohol, very dangerous
drug causes, fights,
causes drunk driving accidents,
leads to cirrhosis of the liver,
completely legal and open.
Our society is not against altered
states of consciousness as such.
It's against particular kinds of altered
states of consciousness that lead to
questioning of the existing
control system. That's what's,
that's what's going on here, here,
here. Well said. And as you know,
I have my own story with, uh,
with, with cannabis and well,
you and I had a moment.
We had a moment which was,
which was quite a life changing
moment for me because I,
if I may just rehearse a little
bit of this for the audience. Um,
in 2011 I had a series
of Iowasca sessions, uh,
in which it was shown to me that I was
using cannabis completely wrong. Uh,
that did become a dominant force
in my life that it was making me,
you're speaking about paranoia and
I agree with your paranoia is a,
is a useful thing if only to overcome it.
That it was making me paranoid that
it was making me suspicious that I
approached everybody around me in a state
of suspicion and I was shown this by
Iowasca and then given a very strong
message, you need to quit cannabis.
What I didn't realize at the time is
that the problem was not cannabis.
The problem was me,
uh,
that I needed to fix those aspects of
myself before I could have a proper
relationship with cannabis.
So after that IOWASCA session,
having smoked cannabis for decades,
literally 16 hours a day,
seven days a week, I quit.
I quit for three years.
And then I'm on your
show and we're sitting,
we're setting up one another as we are
now. And you asked me a question, um,
are you still off the cannabis
and that? And I say, well,
I'm thinking of dipping
my toes back in the water,
at which point you produce a joint and,
and we smoke it together at first of all,
after three years,
your tolerance is way down on cannabis.
I got really stoned.
I did listen to that interview back in.
Somehow I held it together
together brilliantly.
You opened up and there was like a wave
of information came pouring out of you.
It was wonderful.
It wasn't liberation for me.
And what it said to me is it's
time to go back to cannabis. Uh,
but perhaps in a different
way. It doesn't, it,
I need a different relationship
with this amazing medicine. And,
and if I can forge that, if I can make
that different relationship happen,
then it can be a constructive
and positive part of my life.
And I can say definitely that that has
been the case. And that's excellent.
And so it's all thanks to you,
Joe.
I probably would still be off cannabis
if it hadn't been for that joint.